one of the things that's often said
about technological advancements is that
when technology is advancing really
rapidly you can't see it until later
when you're in the middle of it it can
be hard to see even rapid technological
change because you are in the midst of
it every single day we are in the middle
of an authoritarian explosion right now
and if you've been in the middle of the
trump presidency day to day as I haven't
as many of you have for the last I don't
know eleven twelve hundred days roughly
of Donald Trump's presidency you likely
don't realize how quickly things have
gotten authoritarian and dictatorial we
might have some general sense of it but
what has happened in just the last two
weeks really 12 days is shocking and if
someone had told you the day Donald
Trump was inaugurated you know in a 12
day period in 2020 here's the list of
authoritarian things this man is going
to do many of us myself included likely
would have said there's no way it won't
happen but we've slowly been
desensitized it slowly been normalized
and it has happened in the time since
Donald Trump's acquittal as reddit user
rustic guerrilla astutely pointed out
Donald Trump has vowed revenge on his
enemies list after being acquitted in a
completely sham impeachment since the
acquittal the president said that these
are people who will suffer consequences
for their role in impeachment that
includes Adam Schiff and Jerry Nadler
and other Democrats it even includes
Republican Mitt Romney for his one
guilty vote on article one of
impeachment remember impeachment is the
constitutionally outlined duty of the
house a reporter asked Trump how he's
going to get revenge on those
responsible he responded you'll see this
is dictatorial Trump then fired
impeachment witnesses who showed up and
simply told the truth under oath as they
remember it from fired
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN Minh
Trump fired ambassador to the European
Union Gordon Sunland they did nothing
wrong Trump simply doesn't like what
they said when you tell the truth to
investigators under oath and Trump
doesn't like it you lose your job this
is an authoritarian
nightmare Trump's former chief of staff
John Kelly rightly defended Colonel via
Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh and Donald
Trump attacked Kelly tweeting when I
terminated John Kelly which I couldn't
do fast enough he knew full well that he
was way over his head being chief of
staff just wasn't for him he came in
with a bang went out with a whimper but
like so many exes he misses the action
and just can't keep his mouth shut which
he actually has a military and legal
obligation to do his incredible wife
Karen who I have a lot of respect for
once pulled me aside and said strongly
that Jon respects you greatly when we
are no longer here he will only speak
well of you wrong
Trump then as we've already discussed
got involved in the sentencing of his
associate Roger stone interfering in the
trial tweeting quote this is a horrible
and very unfair situation the real
crimes were on the other side as nothing
happens to them cannot allow this
miscarriage of justice again I know I
said this on rehashing it Trump is using
the fact that people not charged with
crimes that he happens not to like
haven't gotten prison time and therefore
stone shouldn't get seven to nine years
dictators do this
dictators attack a justice system that's
working independently and not
considering the subjects relationship to
the president then when for prosecutors
quit because of Trump's own interference
Trump attacks then to Geraldo Rivera
saying over the weekend quote I don't
think they quit for moral reasons I
think they got caught in the act by me
what am I gonna do let a man go to jail
for nine years
when murderers aren't going to jail you
have some of the most serious horrible
rapists and everything else that they
don't go to jail for nine years once
again Trump not using any factual basis
to argue that seven to nine years is
actually out of line with federal
sentencing guidelines but it's not just
the prosecutors that Trump's at Trump
attacks then Trump attacks the judge in
the case
Amy Berman Jackson saying quote is this
the judge that put Paul Manafort in
solitary confinement something that not
even mobster Al Capone had to endure
how did she treat crooked Hillary
Clinton just asking of course remember
Hillary Clinton
not charged with any crimes and of
course as I've already told you based on
the point system that federal sentencing
guidelines employ seven to nine years
was the correct range for Roger stone
and then lastly he's attacked the
prosecutors he's attacked the judge
Trump then attacks one of the jurors in
the Roger stone trial saying quote now
it looks like the foreperson in the jury
in the Roger stone case had significant
bias add that to everything else and
this is not looking good for the quote
Justice Department then he said I didn't
intervene here but I could have if I
wanted to quote the president has never
asked me to do anything in a criminal
case AG bar this doesn't mean the IDI
that I do not have as president the
legal right to do so I do but I have so
far
chosen not to so to sum up the
authoritarian nightmare of the Roger
stone situation you have Trump attacking
the sentence attacking the prosecutors
attacking the judge attacking a juror
and saying he can intervene in any case
if he so pleases and then getting the
Justice Department to change their
sentencing recommendation there's not
really any Justice Department
independence there Trump then on Twitter
accuses the former director of the FBI
robert muller of lying to congress
that's a crime if true trump says
congratulations to attorney general bill
bar for taking charge of a case that was
totally out of control and perhaps
should not even it should not have even
been brought evidence now clearly shows
that the Moller scam was improperly
brought and tainted even bob muller lied
to congress that's an allegation that
the former FBI director has committed a
crime casually by the president on
twitter this is what goes on in
countries that most of us do not
consider ourselves to be equivalent to
in terms of the functioning of our
systems but we are seeing it right here
this would be enough for two terms never
mind twelve days and in the same 12-day
period i don't i won't go into it in
detail trump attacked FBI director
christopher ray former FBI deputy
director Andrew McCabe withdrew the
nomination of Jesse Liu who over
the Roger stone case and McCain and
McCabe's case as head of the DC US
Attorney's Office and on and on and on
so when you put together just the last
12 days
it's an authoritarian nightmare the
likes of which we have not seen from a
president in the United States for a
long time I would argue likely ever
unless someone can give me an example of
where we've seen this level of
authoritarianism not in a four year
period in a 12-day period by a president
this is nothing compared to what we will
see in a potential Trump second term
this was 12 days forget about is it the
12 days of Christmas that song or 12
nights of Christmas I'm Jewish I I don't
but there's 12 nights somewhere I don't
know this is the 12 days of
authoritarianism under Donald Trump and
you could pick any 12 days and do
something similar except he's been madly
and wildly emboldened by the impeachment
acquittal which was predictable we said
this would happen it will get
significantly worse if Trump is given a
second term let me know what you think
about these last 12 days of
authoritarianism I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman follow me and send me your
thoughts there do you feel like you just
don't have enough time to become as
intellectually well-rounded as you would
like to be that they're just not enough
hours in your week for you to read all
of the books that you want to read one
of our sponsors is called blinka stand
it's an app that lets you consume an
entire nonfiction book in 15 minutes
it's only about 8 bucks a month but you
can try it for free for a week and get
25% off a subscription
when you go to blankest comm slash
Pakman what blinka studs is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
and condense them into either text or
audio that you can read or listen to in
just 15 minutes and what you get is all
of the most important ideas and
information from the book imagine being
able to listen to an entire nonfiction
book in the amount of time it takes you
to drive or walk home from work I've
just finished listening to upheaval by
Jared Diamond Jared Diamond a tremendous
author whose work I've previously
recommended excellent book looking at
some of modern history
is biggest national crises to figure out
how different countries ended up in such
precarious situations
blinkie's has totally transformed how I
consume information I love it of course
I read a book in its entirety when I can
but there are simply just so many books
that I want to read and would not have
the time for if it weren't for blinka
stay have books on politics economics
philosophy science you name it you can
try it out yourself totally free for a
week and get 25% off if you decide to
subscribe just by going to blink is comm
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video like the rest of
us I bet you're going into 2020 thinking
about what you didn't get around to in
2019 and your goals for the new year if
you want to work towards being your best
self in 2020 understand more about the
world around you and make sure that your
time is well spent then blink astiz for
you